Okay guys, in this problem we are going to observe the following simply supported
truss and we are going to find the loads in members B and C in kips. So in this
truss we can see that it is supported here and here and members A, B, C and D are
called out. Additionally all of the truss members are the same length and we have
three reaction forces applied at the following joints. So this problem is
asking us just to find the loads in two members here and we can do that with
what is called a force analysis. And really all we are looking for here are
zero force members. Because if we look at the availability of our answers here we
we can see that they are either 200 kips or zero. So we don't need to do any math.
So we can do this problem just by inspection as well. And the way we can do this
is by following three rules to determine if something is a zero force member or
not. So the first rule is if three members form a joint.
The second case is if two members are what we call co-linear and what that means
is they are in the same axis, the same vector and the same plane as each other.
And finally if no external load or reaction occurs at that joint. So if you can
meet these three cases then the third non-co-linear member in your three-member
joint is a zero force member. So let's start doing this by inspection. We could
start with a but because we're not being asked to solve for a I think we should
go right to be. Now we can see here that b has two different sides but we can only
analyze b using the zero force series of rules from this joint up here. So there
are three members in this joint. Two of the members are co-linear. If two of the
members are co-linear as we can see here and finally we have no external load or
reaction at this joint. We do have one beneath it but we are looking at the joint at
the top instead. So using our rules we can determine that there is zero force in member
b. So what this implies here is that these other two diagonal members are taking the
force of the applied load from the joint beneath it. So now that we've solved b, let's
move on to c. We can see that at the top joint there are five members so we can't solve
member c from the top joint. If we go to the bottom of member c we can see that three members
do form a joint here and two of them are co-linear. However rule three is violated because
there is in fact an external load at this joint. So we cannot say that this member here
is a zero force member. So even if we had not solved for c and we had only solved for b so
far we can already determine that two of these answers are wrong. However since we have
also solved for c now we can determine that the third answer here is going to be our correct
answer. And that's it for this problem. If you see a problem like this on the test remember
these three rules and you should be successful in solving it.